we're shutting it down did you send
everybody home stop stop
that it's possibly the worst thing I've
seen so far how do we heat that in the
microwave in the microwave
doesn't even hit another though we used
to cook them fresh right so what what
changed I wasn't here yeah so what
happened
stop I'm not serving it stop what
happened
earth Karen I ain't the one that bought
the chicken I have a brother have a
rotisserie thing back I can have fried
chicken we need no equipment this is
what it's resulted in this is what we're
so he can't buy this for a groceries no
you can't sprinkler it past there and
expect to pull yourselves a restaurant I
know which is I know what to say you
just like a butterfly fly around is
painting all little bits of [ __ ] over
holes this is insane I'm done I'm upset
I'm feeling sick and I've never seen
such a disgusting mess in all my [ __ ]
life its embarrassment to you you you
and me and I'm not gonna stand there and
watch you serve [ __ ] like that and take
customers money what is this I eat them
often the rotisserie you eat them often
is that so
I guess it just that I don't what does
that mean to you you eat this crap often
come on you're one of your hotel
the burgers were cooked yesterday well
when I eat them and I always tell them
they taste it good to me where's the
burgers that you cooked down here sir
get them
i am i understanding you see patting
them out and then put them in the oven
how long for for about fifteen twenty
nine fifteen twenty minutes in another
family your customers expect burgers to
be cooked like that baked in the oven
for 20 minutes there's no color on
they're cooled down
stuck in a ziplock a bag out ball in
water so we're going to do another
survey it's 8% it's just you are
seriously in denial
miss sarah would you like a bite no
thank you why not it's not cooked right
well should I boil it up for you and get
it warm what color is that it's white
that's what frustrates me we're all
pretending that this is good I that's
what the cooks I mean come on not I'm
not trying to blame it on the cooks me
because ain't nobody hearing me I'm
amazed you're not shut down freezers
lined up next to a dumpster what lives
outside and those passageways next to
dumpsters that rat now bats rats and
mice you are in denial you have a big
problem you've got no idea that this
place is crumbling and you just go
through the motions mr. Ramsey my guests
want to leave your guests want to leave
yes as the best thing I've heard all day
can I [ __ ] join them
are we serving food at auction I would
like they don't leave and we're in
danger
I've even been shut down by the Health
Authorities and there is no [ __ ] way
I'm gonna stand there yes sir and watch
my [ __ ] been reheated and served so
sorry we're not moving forward